This guy over here in Germany,
Rudolf Diesel, invented
an engine that changed everything.
This new engine mixed pressure,
and air,
and fossil fuels that all exploded
and made things move.
This changed a lot of industries.
But the Germans were like,
“Let's put these in submarines
and run them to charge
a bunch of batteries
that we can use to power
the sub while we're underwater.”
“It's a lot better than the hand-crank.”
And indeed it was.
But there was one big problem,
which is that
this engine needs air, like,
it needs to be able to pump out
the exhaust that it makes
and it needs to be able to suck in air to
make energy.
So you can't actually run
your engines underwater.
So these German subs, as stealthy as they
were, were still very limited
because they could only stay under water
for like 48 hours max before
having to come up
and give away their position
so that they could get air
for their engines.
This is a problem
that will soon be solved,
but we just need a few wars first.